schavan ja brad pitt
leute über welches thema in katar und
hier sehen wir das mega burg jana an die
vielfalt chefs gianni infantino gern
schon gesagt das wird die größte show
der erde und klar da habe ich als gute
laune rakete natürlich nicht fehlen hier
los gehts richtig gemacht nach dem
sieg eine enttäuschung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
kann ich das gut dann muss man daran
denken für nicht was für ein privileg
ist angesichts des krieges in der
ukraine so erhält los spaß zu haben und
deswegen finde ich auch super dass er
infantino die politische lage nochmals
messerscharf analysiert hatte er gesagt
die welt ist gespalten es gibt viele
auseinandersetzungen lass das mal auf
euch wirken ja und das stadtoberhaupt
von qatar emir tamin bin hamad al thani
der hat sich auch nochmal hingestellt
und knallhart gesagt es ist wichtig dass
wir als menschen auf dieser erde
aufeinander zugehen wo ich wirklich
denke ja ja aufeinander zugehen daran
fehlt es heute total egal ob ich nur
rheinisches kind dessen eltern aus
zerbombt wurde oder irgendwie klar mit
atomar kind am ende sind wir alles
menschen und deswegen ist mir diese
miesepeter rey in bezug auf trab das ist
mir zu deutsch wirklich wm im winter das
war super gerade wenn wir jetzt im
winter vielleicht die heizung nicht auf
5 drehen können weil es das gasfeld das
ist doch super dass wenigstens hand
diese jungs uns ein bisschen die herzen
wärmen
[Musik]
hier und 1 möchte ich den ganzen madig
machen in deutschland mal sagen in katar
da wird keiner über die ja wirklich
niemand und vielleicht auch weil die
meinungsfreiheit stark eingeschränkt ist
ja keine freie presse geht ja aber das
ist wieder der westliche blick von oben
herab unangenehm und engstirnig
wir haben sonst schön unverstellten
blick auf die dinge und da haben sie
sich gefragt was ist eigentlich das
geile am fußballtore ja und haben sie
gemerkt meinungsfreiheit schießt keine
tore das kann sich die bundesrepublik
natürlich wieder die vorstellen er
letztendlich ist katar ein sympathisches
familienunternehmen hier da gibt es
kaffee mir das land an den sohnemann
reiter seit generationen komplett ohne
dass wirtschaft zivilgesellschaft oder
wähler ja irgendwie komisch mitmischen
ich finds erfrischend sind wir in so
einer komplizierten welt apropos
erfrischen ich muss erst mal
[Musik]
hintereinander dann
alle werbe spots verkauf für die web ja
das ist der hammer
also nachdem ard und zdf 214 millionen
für die wm rechte hingeblättert haben
geht wenigstens die darum herum weg wie
warme semmeln und da können wir
vielleicht noch kurz auf kritik eingehen
jetzt mal die werbung weg ist nur ein
bisschen also dann haben wir hinter uns
ich würde sagen also ganz kurz die wm in
katar wird nicht nur ne geile show
sondern auch leuchtturm für westliche
werte also zum beispiel konsum also ich
sag mal führen ja spaß betonten umgang
mit ressourcen führen
unverkrampftes verhältnis zu geld ja und
die fifa geht die werte hier wirklich ja
wirklich also schon 2009 als im fifa
exekutivkomitee über die wm-vergaben
abgestimmt wurde er hat qatar die
abstimmung klar geworden weil drei
mitglieder sich nicht haben blenden
lassen von trockenen fakten über
menschenrechtsverletzungen sondern
einfach ja leidenschaft gefolgt sind für
geld auf dem eigenen konto und als er
später rausgekommen ist das hat die
stimmen gekauft wurden da hat man die
nicht verklagt sondern so wichtig ist
aufeinander zugegangen und hat gesagt
wir machen es ja so stimmen zu kaufen
weit weniger erfolg
christian redmann
das ist genau wie orte sport steigt die
sonne häufiger zu hause aus tischen
steht ein so empfindlich wie
konstruktive optimismus dass man nicht
auch hier menschenrechtlerin rbl so dass
man sagt ja stimmen wir einfach für uns
dafür investieren wir durch unsere
schule bei oder rüber auf werden dürfen
dann über uns stadion bauen win win win
also außer jetzt für die für die 6000
fahrgäste weiter die beim bau der
stadien ums leben gekommen ja also gut
muss man sagen jetzt win win win los
drei zu eins immer noch ein deutlicher
sieg
war es ist aber auch lecker ist schon
weg ja aber ich bin trotzdem voll
wichtig dass man das mit den toten
gastarbeitern echte mal wieder man
spricht also dass das nicht okay ist zum
beispiel wenn man neue geschäfte machen
mit katar dass man immer größer zu sache
hier übrigens das mit den arbeitern
hatte das in der zeitung gelesen und
wissen ja dann oft gar nicht weil das in
den zeitungen steht
6.500 tote gastarbeiter da ist natürlich
die erste frage die bei uns allen auf
klopp ist es eigentlich viel 6500 wie
viel ist 6500 eigenen fußballplätzen man
hat ja gar keine vorstellung also wenn
man die jetzt nebeneinander beerdigt
einmal zieht die maße des kleinsten
standard gravis heran dann sind es
ungefähr zwei fußballplätze
und amnesty international geht sogar von
15.000 toten aus da muss man sagen gut
dass sie gleich zwölf fußballfelder
gebaut haben das läppert sich schnell so
hat das wahrscheinlich auch franz
beckenbauer gemeint und der war mehrmals
in katar oder gesagt ich habe in katar
keinen einzigen sklaven gesehen
sie waren alle schon vergraben okay zwei
fußballfelder voller toter das klingt
viel aber sollte man deswegen gleich die
wm ausfallen lassen die haben ja auch
angehörige die jetzt super traurig sind
und was ist das einzige was den jetzt
hilft
genau fußball ja was ist denn
lebensbejahender als upgrade fußballs
ist mir erwartet gerade so versessen
darauf so schön war schön weil ich dir
recht der reiseverläufe noch wo an der
kleineren der weiß nicht aber wenn es da
alles gestanden hätte sehr megageil kann
das gar nicht so gemeint hat es noch
drauf
ich muss wissen dass egal ich nehme euch
direkt investiert ich bin so wie die mit
animalischer auf das ist ja das geil auf
fußball
okay sie jetzt nicht und die
arbeitsmigranten den katar scheiße
behandelt werden also frauen zb haben in
katar deutlich weniger rechte als männer
häusliche gewalt und vergewaltigung in
der ehe sie nach wie vor strafe gut muss
man schon sagen ja wenn ein mann eine
frau vergewaltigt aber danach sagt der
sex sei einvernehmlich gewesen wird oft
die frau allein bestraft wegen
außerehelichen geschlechtsverkehr aber
hey obwohl darauf sieben jahren
gefängnis stehen werden die meisten
frauen nur zu einem jahr knast
verurteilt ist das was da ist sie wieder
diese lockerheit
nur ein jahr knapp für diese vorne katar
den geht's ja damit im durchschnitt
doppelt so gut wie wird stärker
großbritannien ist ja das ist nämlich
für zwei jahre her da sitzt dann wenn
wir nichts los überhaupt ist partner in
sachen minderheitenrechten rasant auf
dem weg in die zukunft hier regenbogen
fahren zum beispiel sind in katar
ausdrücklich erlaubt
ja also okay jetzt nur für uns touristen
das während der wm und idealerweise nur
rund um die stadien aber herr sommers
klar gibt es da kataris die von den
sicherheitsbehörden während der wm mit
regenbogenfahne gefilmt werden und dann
erst nach den spielen ausgepeitscht
werden ja aber katar ist einfach noch
ein staat der sich selber an homophobie
kümmert
so ursprünglich und da muss man einen
homosexuellen noch mal sagen bitte bitte
nicht vergessen auch trotz peitschen
heben auf die leute zugehen ja und was
mich ärgert in deutschland ist dieses
absichtliche falsch verstehen ja es
stimmt dass der damalige fifa präsident
sepp blatter bei der wm-vergabe gesagt
hat schwule und lesben sollten bei der
wm jegliche sexuellen aktivitäten
unterlassen aber doch nur weil so heißt
es da unten er hat einfach angst dass
die sich beim sex vor ausgaben und dann
hitzeschlag kriegen wie die 6500 touren
gastarbeiter die es nicht gibt da ist
jetzt auch eine gefahr bei hetero 6
dabei ist der blatter offenbar das
kriegt man auch ohne anstrengungen ja
aber wie machen wir das land mit der wm
noch weltoffener mit fußball natürlich
deshalb geht auch hier wieder das
erfolgsmodell wandel durch annäherung
wir zaubern eine geile show auf dem
rasen haben die pressefreiheit die haben
schwulenrechte die schaffen die scharia
abwehr klar ist doch logisch wenn sein
autoritärer scheich erst mal sieht was
für ein super typ der thomas müller ist
da sagte sich der leute das waren eric
mit dem auspeitschen lassen mal ein
bisschen lässiger werden ja klar ja
natürlich statt frauen zu unterdrücken
einfach mal eine kühle müller milch
trinken ja da sieht die welt gleich ganz
anders aus wenn der herren fußball
vereins steht in der welt dann ja für
frauenrechte und fristen locker umgehen
mit homosexualität
wandel durch annäherung ist es so
wichtig ich mein deutschland ist das
beste beispiel
die haben hier noch 36
zehn jahre später hatten wir eine
demokratie deshalb ist das jetzt echt
quatsch zu sagen oder die wm in russland
und die olympischen spiele in china die
haben die regimes noch autoritärer
gemacht da sage ich
menschenrechte sind wir gut herein die
brauchen zeit ja klar
ja und es hat ja auch die deutsche
wirtschaft startet die sagen ja zu
bestellungen aus katar und zu
menschenrechtsverletzungen sagen
nein also ich meine ja nein vielleicht
also wir haben es gesehen außerdem
brauchen wir den umsatz und sonst macht
er die konkurrenz auf verbindung ist
ganz schlecht
stark oder ok sehen es gibt unternehmen
die das anders sehen zum beispiel die
niederländische firma henriks gras die
hat sich aus ethischen gründen geweigert
rollrasen nach katar zu liefern aber hey
so verpasst man natürlich auch die
riesige chance die kataris von
westlichen werten zu überzeugen zum
beispiel in seiner kleinen
regenbogenfahne auf der rechnung so hoch
mehr willst du ihn hast du klassiker ist
das offizielle maskottchen der wm in
katar das ist der geist der toten
gastarbeiter als maskottchen ahmed das
ist doch schön dass die noch gewürdigt
werden oder glück gehabt der und keine
angst die langfristige zusammenarbeit
von deutschland mit katar steht nicht in
frage wirtschaftsminister hat es gerade
noch mal bestätigt als er in doha eine
energiepartnerschaft vereinbart hat weil
er die uns die preise nach belieben
diktieren können einfach weil das so
eine starke beziehung ist würde es wie
im privaten was hat beziehung war
jahrtausende stabil gehalten was ist das
stärkste band zwischen zwei menschen
genau abhängigkeit und deutschland hat
sich so abhängig gemacht von seinen
autokratischen freunden dass das der
beziehung gar nichts anhaben kann dass
man dabei ersten zeichen von
menschenrechtsverletzungen also kleine
meinungsverschiedenheiten dass man da
nicht gleich die brocken hinwirft
sondern stattdessen konstruktiv
aneinander vorbei redet dass man sagt da
bin ich selber in der dusche aus gewusst
warum gleich schluss machen wegen
grundlegenden moralischen differenzen
hier unmoralischer sich deutschland
verhält desto kleiner ist auch die
differenz mal so gedacht wandel durch
annäherung ist doch keine einbahnstraße
und deshalb
gut dass wir uns das alles mal von der
seele geredet haben oder sitzung besser
oder ich habe jetzt noch mehr bock auf
die wm viel spaß das war's
die haben gesagt die sollen meinen
lieblings witz erzählt es mache ich
gerne also kommen ein pferd chef base
und der papst in eine bar sagt der
barkeeper
abonniere endlich den zwei takten heute
schon kanal also geht doch
[Musik]